krankheiten die man eigentlich dachte
besiegt zu haben tauchen plötzlich
wieder auf und zwar gefährlicher denn je
und das trotz impfung wären die
eigentlich an einem gleichgewicht mit
ihrem wird interessiert sind um sich
selbst so am besten auszubreiten werden
plötzlich zu gnadenlosen killers
verschaffen wir uns mit impfung also
gerade nur ein paar jahre ruhe vor alten
feinden verlieren wir mit ihrer
wirksamkeit die wichtigste waffe der
medizin und was tun experten und
expertinnen gegen diesen gefährlichen
trend das alles und noch viel mehr jetzt
bei klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen mittlerweile wird schon der
dritte impfstoff gegen dem sogenannten
marek virus eingesetzt dem killer ganze
hühnerhöfe das virus hat bereits zwei
generationen an impfstoffen überwunden
und das ist kein einzelfall sondern ein
fataler trend in der medizin in den 60er
jahren wurde der erste impfstoff gegen
die marek wären eingeführt zwanzig jahre
später waren sie zurück und töteten auch
die geimpft lüner ein weiterer impfstoff
kam auf den markt zehn jahre später
waren wieder neue viren da und der
impfstoff machtlos mittlerweile ist man
beim impfstoff nummer drei angelangt
denn die marek wären schaffen es immer
wieder die impfstoffe auszutricksen und
forschungsteams sind ratlos wie das
passiert festhalten kann man nur die
viren werden immer besser die impfstoffe
leider nicht dazu der virologe jakob
trimpert von der uni berlin
dieses virus hat schon ein paar
impfstoff generationen überwunden wie im
rechten verstehen warum es nach so
mühelos schafft und wie man verhindern
könnte dass es dabei immer gefährlicher
wird
wenn das marek virus zuschlägt überlebt
nur jedes fünfte händchen stelle sind
wie leergefegt und die bauern machtlos
und es ist besonders tückisch denn das
virus befällt ausgerechnet die zellen
die es beseitigen sollen die immunzellen
die viren schleusen ihre eigene dna in
die zelle und vervielfältigen ihr
eigenes genmaterial so oft bis das
immunsystem des huhns zusammenbricht das
fatale daran die aktuellen erreger sind
gefährlicher und aggressiver als
diejenigen die 1907 erstmalig
beschrieben wurden gilt das etwa auch
für andere viren oder bakterien die erst
durch die impfungen besser werden
gilt das auch für erreger die mensch
infizieren ins experten und expertinnen
sind ratlos denn sie fürchten fatale
folgen impfgegner könnten sich darauf
stürzen und die impfraten die derzeit
sowieso auf sehr niedrigen niveau sind
weiter in den keller stürzen lassen
dazu biologe markus trimpert auf jeden
fall ist dass marek virus ein beispiel
für eine ungewöhnlich rasante evolution
und die impfung ist höchstwahrscheinlich
der motor seine entwicklung in seinen
studien erstellt ja eine evolution skate
in der das erbgut der viren von 1940 bis
heute aufschlüsselt auffällig dabei die
aktuell kursierenden stämme zeigen eine
extrem hohe verwandlung aktivität und
zwar bei den transkriptionsfaktoren
steuereinheiten quasi die die weichen im
hühner stoffwechsel so stellen dass das
virus sich vermehren kann immer wenn ein
neuer impfstoff eingeführt wird tauchen
genau von diesen steuereinheit neue
effektivere varianten auf und gegen
diese können dann auch antikörper nichts
mehr ausrichten ein riesiges problem
dass man bei der impfstoffentwicklung so
bislang noch nicht im blick hatte dazu
der us-forscher android irgendwie gingen
immer alle davon aus dass evolution bei
impfungen keine rolle spielt ja tut sie
aber und heute sind wir alle live dabei
beim größten experiment das die
evolutionsforschung die veranstaltet hat
denn bislang stand bei der
impfstoffentwicklung immer der
sogenannte mobilisierungs test im
mittelpunkt der forschung bindet das
gebildete antikörper nach der impfung
fest genug an das oberflächen molekül
des krankheitserregers und markiert den
eindringlingen so dabei spielte in den
köpfen der forschungsteams bislang keine
rolle ob ein reger in der lage ist
dieses markierungs system auszutricksen
manche experten und expertinnen sehen
das als hinweis denn impfstoffe von
früher hielten auf erreger wie pocken
oder masern die man eben nur einmal im
leben haben kann
diese viren sind wohl nicht
spezialisiert darauf die immunabwehr von
lebewesen zu umgehen und umso
aggressiver zurückzukehren hier gilt
also weiterhin wer diese krankheiten
einmal hatte und überlebt ist ein leben
lang immun genauso wie diejenigen die
geimpft sind also das muss man
differenziert betrachten das ist also
nicht wasser auf die mühlen
von impfgegnern doch ein fazit das man
aus der aktuellen lage ziehen kann ist
wohl dass nicht alle infektionen für
impfungen geeignet sind das gilt für
diejenigen viren die strategien
entwickeln können die antikörper
auszutricksen und dann ein zweites mal
aggressive angreifen darunter zählen
auch impfungen die menschen betreffen
beispielsweise haben sich hepatitis b
viren und auch die pneumokokken
bakterien seit der zulassung der impfung
vor etwa 20 jahren entwickelt die
südostasiatischen mutanten der hepatitis
b viren können auch geimpfte anstecken
und verursachen häufiger leberkrebs als
die ursprüngliche virusvariante dennoch
betonen forschungsteams eindringlich das
ist kein generelles problem mit
impfungen gibt dazu android wir haben
ein problem bei den erregern die mit dem
immunsystem interagieren können es gibt
immer mehr erreger die auf die impfungen
mit anpassungen reagieren und es bleibt
dabei also ganz wichtig impfungen sind
die einzige mögliche vorsorge gegen
lebensgefährliche krankheiten nach
meinung des experten müsse den wären die
chance auf evolution genommen werden
beispielsweise durch hohe impfraten aber
auch ein überwachungssystem das nach in
freest enten stemmen sucht wäre denkbar
andere forschungsteams sehen eine
möglichkeit in der entwicklung von
reserve impfstoffen die man einsetzen
könnte wenn es zu neuen ausbrüchen kommt
denn es gilt normalerweise haben wären
niemals das ziel tödlich zu sein denn
sie sind ja auf ihrem wirt angewiesen um
sich auszubreiten besonders aggressive
erreger hatten bei diesen spielern also
einen enormen wettbewerbsnachteil
doch genau da vergeht sich jetzt ins
gegenteil werden besonders schädlich ist
gewinnt schafft es besonders schnell in
die wirtszelle und kann sich am besten
aus brighton unter der voraussetzung
dass der wirt organismus geimpft ist
wenn die viren aber auf ungeimpfte
treffen werden sie zu gnadenlosen
killers
so jetzt gibt es ein geschenk für euch
vielen dank an technology review in
zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion dieser
ziemlich guten zeitschrift ist dieses
video entstanden und exklusiv für klicks
um zuschauerinnen und zuschauer habe ich
jetzt ein geschenk ihr bekommt nämlich
eine ausgabe gratis wenn ihr auf diesen
link klickt das lohnt sich absolut ist
es eine super zeitschrift ja und auf
jeden fall klicks und natürlich
abonnieren das geht hier glocke nicht
vergessen und jetzt weiter dafür auch
drauf klicken
so fühlt es sich an zu sterben bis dann
bleibt dann